[拍手]
今日はどうもありがとうございました。
今、あなたがそれをやめようと思ったとき、あなたはあなたの人生の時間を短縮したことがありますか？
そんな風に感じたことはありませんでしたが、今までに一度も
一緒にいられなかったのですが、
中身は大丈夫です。私の名前
はリタです。22歳で
、カメラに向かって話している自分の動画をアップロードしています。
私の寝室で一人で
YouTubeでほぼ毎週必要です
はい私の裸の地下室で雇われた
仕事は両方ともかなり怖いですが
あなたの心で安心して見てみましょうしかしもっと
重要なことに私は同じ経験
をしました そうです、私は
リマの山を一生懸命頑張っていますが、私はただ滑り落ち続け
ていますが、
特にYouTube
での経験で私を止めた人は誰も
いませんでしたが、私はより強い人になる必要がありますが、それを感じるためにあなたがしなければならないことを示唆していません
あなたがそれを見ようとし続ける
なら、それはすべてです
積極性に関連していて、実際には、この部屋でInstagramを使用し
ている人が少し散りばめられている
のを
見ることができます。
Instagram
の権利は右側にあり、その前に立っていたわけではありません。
このトリートメントのすべてのスターバックス
は、これが私のオンラインの画像であり、一部の
人々は私のInstagramからの私の画像、
または私がオンラインで投稿して考えているものを見る可能性があると言ってい
ます これ
は、私の写真をすべて知っていることをうめき声を上げます。どちらも
素晴らしい場所のように見えます
。YouTubeやソーシャル
メディアのフォロワーや、 私
にとってはそうです私は非常に前向きに生きていることをあなたが知っていることを認めます私は私の
人生に非常に満足している美しい人生を持っています
しかし私がその時点に到達するために私
が経験しなければならないことがたくさんあり
ました 14歳でした
o それはかなり個人的なことですが
、私が14歳のとき、あなたは私が10代であることを知っ
ています。あなたは自分の
自己イメージについて心配する必要
はありません。
冬休みが過ぎた
ので、クリスマスディナーのタイム
パックを食べ物に飲みすぎて
、高校生のときに20代の新年の決意があったとしても、
その量の体重が減るだろうと
思いました。 私は得ました、
そして最初はそれは私がちょうどそのコンプを閉めるつもりだということを知っていることから始まりまし
た
誰も少しの間軽食をやめませんでした
がそれからすぐにエスカレートしました私は
朝食を食べるのをやめました私は昼食を食べるのをやめ
ました 最速の
ランナーは私にすべてを信頼しますが、あなた
は私が空のスタントの膝で誰と競争するかを知っています
なぜなら e私は
あなたがそのように失うことを知っていることを考えることにとても夢中に
なりました私は私がとても孤独を感じたので私のすべての友人を幸運にし
ました 彼女はとても協力的です
彼女はいつもあなたが他の人
にとって非常に場所を意味するものは何でも知ってい
ます
が、ある日彼女は私に
近づき、私の髪が地面に落ちたのを見て
、
私は文字通り髪の塊のように
丸くなりました パルスステージと私の
医者は私を非常に心配していました、そして
彼女は私に出てきました、そして彼女は私たちが
終わったと言い
ました 初めて自分自身を見たとき、私
は自分自身に
飛び、外に出て自分自身を考え、
この女の子は
とても孤独で、
彼女が何をしているのかわからないので助けが必要だ
と言い
ました。 私がvidを作ることを発見したとき eos
onlineそれは有名になり始めた頃の読み物でした、
そして私
はすべての女の子
が私が持っていなかったすべてのものに自信を持っていることへの美しさと情熱に情熱を注いでいるのを見るでしょう
そして私はそのようになりたいと思っ
ていましたが 私にこの混乱
をさせるために私が完全にゼロ状態から外れているとき私はそれをすることができない
ので私はそこで私の性交を変えることに決めました
そして
あなたは私が何でもなくなるつもりであるとあなたは知っています
それは私が
やり続けたいことであり、それが
私のドライブになりたいと思っています。積極性はあなたの人生で何をするかを決める選択なので、あなたがそのように壮大なことをしなければならないことをあなたが知っていることを示唆していません
あなたが正しくコントロールしているので
、母が私に収入の言葉を言ったとしても、15こんにちはハニーと言いましょう。私は
私の人生を生きるつもりだと思っていました。私は
この人が座っている私だけで1つのことをするつもりです。
私の前で大丈夫です今日は全然で
はなく、私がハスバンになることを選んだからです d
そして
、
それが私をひっくり返し、彼を隠すために私の目をパンツに変えたときに、どの島がその認識を変えるべきかを考えたので、それは私の
最大の恐怖を克服したいの
です。
彼らは常にソーシャルメディアを利用しているので難しいことです。
私がソーシャルメディアを利用しているので、
ちょっと変なことを知っているかもしれませ
ん。
他の人
はあなたのように良くなるためにそれは常に
あなたの足元にあること
を知っていますあなたはあなたがそうだ
という
ことを知っています
なぜそれが私に起こって以来、
私は常に自分自身に挑戦することを決心しました
、そしてそれ
はあなたが知っているところで私を
それほど助けませんでした
私の人生を手に入れよう私は何でもできますそしてはい
それは誰にとっても難しいことです私はあなた
がいつも私が支払われたコメントを受け取ることを知っていることを意味します
私が
最も言いたいのは、何かに影響を与えるために自分自身を屈服させなければならないということです。
何でも、それが
私の人生を動かし続けること
が私のモチベーションになることを本当に望んでいます、
そして私は再び地球上で大丈夫で完璧な人ではないかもしれませんが、
私はそれで
完全に元気ですそしてあなた全体のために-
それは大丈夫です-そして私は願っています その
魚が今日あなたの価格のどこかで出会うなら
、あなたはそれ
をあなたと一緒に取り上げることができます
[拍手]